welcome to the man of recaps this is
house of the dragon episode three we
start right off with the crab feeder
this pirate who wears a weird mask and
apparently just really likes feeding
people to crabs but what's this coming
in it's a dragon yeah breathing fire
dragons are awesome but he and his crew
are really fortified in these caves it
nullifies the dragon advantage now back
in king's landing there's been a time
jump it's straight up three years later
remember the king the cyrus targaryen
married his daughter's best friend
alison tytower and now they have a
two-year-old son aegon many lords of the
realm have come out for his birthday
they're going to go on a great hunt and
the speculation is now that he has a son
he's going to name aegon heir to the
iron throne his daughter rhaenyra's out
of luck rhaenyra has apparently been in
a three-year bad mood mad at her former
best friend and her father for you know
getting married without telling her and
now having his son to push her out of
the line of succession but now it's time
for the hunt which is basically like a
three-day party and hirono meets lord
jason lannister and much like his
eventual descendants he is kind of a
rich d-bag and he's spitting his best
game here yeah he's trying to marry
renera in fact he's already talked to
her dad about it ranira has no interest
in marrying anyone right now and is mad
at her father even more but it's like
hey daughter you're the princess it's
your duty to marry a strong lord to
secure our family alliances and more
than that you know have kids to make
more targaryen heirs rainier throws a
tantrum and rides on out of there so
she's followed by her bodyguard the
kingsguard knight sir christine cole yes
last episode we saw there was an opening
she got to pick the new one and it was
sir kristen who i remember beats damon
targaryen in the tourney in episode one
answer kristen seems like a real good
guy he and raniera are kind of friends
and they skip the rest of the hunt to
have their own little camping trip in
fact it's pretty exciting when they're
attacked by a wild boar this boar is
just like real aggressive for some
reason patreonera takes it out now king
viserys wants to be a good king and a
good father he's a nice guy this one
advisor we haven't seen too much yet
lionel strong is like hey king i have
some advice remember three years ago you
almost married cordless valerian's
daughter because she was a great match
well the valerians are still a great
match he's got a son about rainier's age
boom in any case the talk of the hunt is
that they've spotted the majestic white
buck the king of the forest and it seems
like an omen that the birthday boy aegon
will be king but the hunt never finds
the white buck they just find a normal
big buck and uh take that one down
because the white buck king of the
forest pays a visit to ranira i mean you
know it depends if you believe in omens
but this sort of signifies that she
should be queen she doesn't kill the
buck she lets it live but when she comes
back to the hunting camp covered in
blood because she killed this awesome
boar everyone here is kind of like okay
girl you're a badass now hand of the
king otto hightower knows it's best for
the realm if there is a male heir and
plus it's better for him if his grandson
is king he talks to his daughter like
hey you gotta convince the king to name
your son air it's better if it comes
from you but queen allison doesn't for
now she seems just like a really nice
person who likes her king viserys and
wants to help him do what's best for the
realm and his family instead what they
talk about is the latest letter he got
talking about the crab feeder and how
the war is going real bad now remember
the realm is not at war with the crab
feeder it's just corliss valerian and
damon targaryen doing an unsanctioned
military action the king's like look
they disobeyed my commands to start this
war i can't step in and help it'll make
me look weak allison's like hey i get
that but if you look at it from another
angle you stepping in to save the day
now will make you look like the good guy
so in the morning he sends the messenger
saying the royal fleet's coming but
first he talks with his daughter ranira
and they have a heart to heart he's like
daughter i don't want to fight anymore i
want you to be happy he's like look you
gotta marry but i won't get involved you
pick whoever you want it's fine and two
let me just spell it out for ya i swear
i will not name aegon or my future kids
heirs you're going to be queen i'm
sticking to it so yeah this is all
awesome for ranira viserys getting
father of the year award so now we go to
the war and the stepstones against the
crab peter now cordless valerian the sea
snake has a brother but also a son lane
or valerian who's the one lord strong
recommended vernier mary anyway long
story short this war is not going well
like we saw at the beginning the crab
beater and his men are hiding in all
these caves they can't make progress
they have one idea to send one person in
basically as bait to lure their forces
out and then they can catch them in an
ambush but it would have to be one of
the high lords and none of them want to
go on a suicide mission but now the
messenger from king's landing comes with
the letter that the king is stepping in
sending the royal fleet to come save the
day but the king's brother damon
targaryen does not like this news in
fact he starts beating the messenger
obviously they need the help but if the
king steps in then damon you know lost
and was a huge failure and damon can't
have that especially because he still
does plan to be king and to get the
realm on his side he needs to come out
of here with a glorious victory not an
embarrassing defeat and so damon
targaryen rolls up solo with the white
flag like come on get me crap beater but
as the men come out for him oh it was a
trick yeah he's attacking going on the
solo assassination mission and it's an
awesome sequence as the arrows are
flying but it's kind of hard to hit one
guy and damon is an absolute beast an
army would get slaughtered trying to
attack this point but one guy he can
take him out one by one as he's going
finally they send a bunch of guys at him
and a couple arrows do hit him so he's
got to take cover and as a ton of the
crappier's men run out to get him what's
this yes the trap is sprung the
valarians are here to flank them and
more than that it's a dragon yeah
but who's this dragon rider it seems
like it is lane or valerian who is half
targaryen on his mother's side and it's
an epic battle sequence as our guys are
getting victory in fact damon targaryen
himself went for the off-screen 1v1 with
a crab beater and won so yeah this was
the ultimate power move on damon's part
right when the king had finally caved
and sent help damon bust in on the epic
suicide mission i didn't need your help
bro and that's where house of the dragon
episode 3 comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies
[Music]